good evening and welcome to this Newseum
program on President Kennedy has been
shot
I'm Peter Pritchard I'm president of the
Newseum and the Freedom Forum the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy is indelibly etched in the
memories of all Americans who are old
enough to remember that tragedy I think
it's fair to say that everyone who was
alive at that time remembers where he or
she was I remember that I read the first
UPI bulletins of the event at the office
of my college newspaper and we were all
in a state of shock for the journalists
that of that day it was the biggest
story they would ever cover it also
created a conflict as they wrestled to
contain their own emotions while
rendering a dispassionate account of
what happened the Newseum book President
Kennedy has been shot tells the
minute-by-minute story of the
assassination from the vantage point of
the journalists who were there I would
like to take a moment to thank the
people and organizations who made this
book possible first the author's Cathy
Trost and Susan Bennett Cathy and Susan
can you stand up and take a bow there
you are
next our agent Rafe's a galleon Rafe are
you here right back there I can't do
business without Rhett without an agent
our publisher source books and it's top
executive Dominique Rocca Dominique
where's Dominique back all right and
we'd also like to thank US News and
World Report which excerpted the book in
this week's issue and we'd especially
like to thank all of the journalists who
took their time to remember what
happened on that fateful day some of
those reporters are here tonight of
course on the panel and elsewhere and
they will be around later tonight along
with our co-authors to sign books and if
you're interested in more on this story
CNN will rebroadcast the documentary
President Kennedy has been shot which is
based on the book on Saturday November
22nd at 8:00 and 11:00 p.m. our mission
at the Newseum is to tell the story
behind the news and this book is a
beautiful example of what we try to do
as many of you know we're building a new
Newseum at sixth in Pennsylvania there's
a rendering of it right over there it's
next to the Canadian Embassy and across
the street from the National Gallery of
Art it will be three times larger than
the first museum it's a beautiful glass
and steel transparent building designed
by James Stewart Paul Scheck who did the
Rose Center at the American Museum of
Natural History in New York as you can
see from that rendering the first
amendment will appear in very large
letters on a limestone tablet on the
front of the building that'll be the
first amendment between the White House
and the Capitol I know Helen Thomas will
appreciate that among others and we are
looking forward to inviting all of you
to our Grand Opening early in 2007 the
Newseum parent foundation is the Freedom
Forum which works to support free press
free speech and free spirit and this
ambitious project would never have been
possible without the vision and the big
checkbook of our chairman and chief
executive Charles Overby who is sitting
right over there tonight
our moderator tonight is Bob Schieffer
the chief Washington correspondent for
CBS News and the host of Face the Nation
back in 1963 bob was a young reporter
for the Fort Worth star-telegram if you
see the CNN video you will see Bob as a
young reporter wearing a large gray
Fedora broad brimmed hat it makes him
look older yeah he wasn't wearing it for
that reason though he was wearing it
because the old-timers in the newsroom
said it would look make him look more
like a cop and he could get closer to
the action and believe it or not in
those days that worked how times have
changed please welcome our moderator for
this evenings panel a great reporter Bob
Schieffer well thank you very much and
let me just quickly introduce the panel
here and next to me Sid Davis in those
days Sid was with Westinghouse
broadcasting Westinghouse went one of
the great Washington bureaus back in the
days when radio maintained large bureaus
here and they they had one of the best
Sid later was the bureau chief for NBC
in a vice president for NBC Moe
colleague icarus Pappas back here
longtime CBS News correspondent and as
you'll find out Ike had a chance to see
the extraordinary thing that happened
when they brought Oswald out to transfer
him to the county jail Ike was at the
city jail
I was waiting over at the county jail
that of course
Oswald never got there and then my old
friend Bob Clark longtime correspondent
for ABC Bob Clark saw this he is the
last surviving member of the press pool
that day when they were all in Dallas
and Bob also saw the assassination of
Bobby Kennedy let me just start here
with you Bob you were just three cars
behind the car carrying President
Kennedy when you heard the gunshots what
went through your head and tell us what
you heard and saw okay get it straight
fax me we were the fifth car fifth car
that's close enough for TV the principal
remember the press star in that pool car
of course was Marilyn Smith but there
were four reporters and Mac Kilduff who
sadly died this last year as the acting
White House press secretary we were just
making the turn into the sharp
intersection in front of the Texas
School Book Depository when the first
shot rang out that which we thought was
I thought was sounded more like a loud
backfire but then two more quickly in a
total of six or seven or eight seconds
and the shots were extremely loud very
clear and what is more significant they
were fired from we all felt from our
immediate area from up above us and we
were almost underneath the sixth floor
window where Oswald was firing so that
you wanted me to go a little farther but
we when there were the three shots were
fired at Merriman Smith who I knew was a
gun fancier said those words shots and
we accepted the fact that they work and
that our car came to a halt for a few
seconds just long enough for some
strange things to happen
a police man on a motorcycle pulled up
in front of us jumped off his motorcycle
and pulled out as a revolver and went
roaring up onto the grassy knoll the you
may have wondered some of you that I
find people just accept this there was
just behind us and the motorcade a pool
car of photographers but there are no
pictures of Kennedy
the the press goes to great expense to
follow the president wherever he goes so
there always be pictures why aren't
there of the assassination oh yeah well
let me just interrupt did you then did
the the pool car go on out to the
hospital with with the president after
it speeded up I was going yes okay the
press pool card the writing press but
the photographer's followed their basic
instincts as photographers jumped out
and followed the action instead of
carrying out their primary duty of
following the president and so they they
were just left behind when the motorcade
suddenly took off very rapidly as fast
as it could accelerate again the
photographers were all left behind and
it was only our pool car that went on to
the house onto the house we get just to
substantiate your story we became the
third car I guess because we we we
pulled out and passed the vice
president's car which yeah now I do work
for what w ne W which is what a New York
radio station the New York radio station
very rich and powerful station could
afford to send people like me around
where will you win the when the shots
rang out
where were you when the shots well I was
not in Dallas I was in New York City I
had a day off I worked Tuesday well I
worked Sunday to Thursday in those days
I had Friday and Saturday off and my
plan was to have a wonderful day off
walking around Greenwich Village and I
had to go to the dentist first painless
Pete koutris who was still my dentist
and so I told him I'd give him a plug
every time I could
so what happened you got AK well I've
been I'm gonna I'm getting to it and I'm
trying I'm trying like hell not to call
you Dan tonight anyway I went through
with my plan I I went to the dentist and
he got done real fast and that was
getting toward lunchtime and I said well
I'm going down to Greenwich Village and
hop I hopped on a train I have done a
subway came out in West 4th Street and
as soon as I hit the street this lady
came running up to me and she was
hysterical
she was screaming the president had been
shot the president's dead the president
shot and she was crying and her face was
was wetted down with her tears and I
could remember her hair falling over in
front of her face because she was crying
so much and and I'm a bit of a cynic in
those days I said to myself well when
tonight when the tourists come down lady
you can tell him that story I don't
believe it but then I noticed something
that was happening in New York City and
you don't see it quite often and that is
people were starting to talk to each
other they were stopping and talking and
there was an electricity in the air and
I said ah could it be and I went running
over to the phone booth and across the
way across 6th Avenue and I put a nickel
in the slot and they were it was a
nickel in those days and I called my
office and as soon as the phone was
answered any W I could hear and and the
guy didn't have to tell me the editor
did not have to tell me because I could
hear Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
bulletins going and the people shouting
the teletypes going telephones ringing
and I said what's this about Kennedy and
all he said and this is for to be
historically correct he said get your
ass up here and I jumped into a cab and
I'm a heart sank my first thought was
they got him who was they the
segregationists there was there was a
lot of fear a lot of trepidation at that
time that he should not go to Dallas
because there was a threats against his
life perhaps and everybody was saying
that you know because of his standing
against civil rights I mean I mean for
civil rights rather and against the
segregationist in the south and and
there were warnings that he shouldn't go
in my hearts
and I grabbed a cab and these are
details that I think are not
historically necessary but are
interesting I jumped into the cab and I
said get me up to 46th Street and 5th
Avenue immediately and I kept throwing
money at him and he said what's going on
I said well turn on the radio I need to
hear the radio at that point I didn't
know whether the president was alive or
dead or what had happened to him but in
any event he said to be blue turn on the
radio and the radio announcers said that
President Kennedy had been shot and I
don't think that we knew at that point
whether he was dead or not and he turns
around to me and he said are you in his
cab driver in New York City says you
mean I got that guy Johnson to worry
about now you know all he had to on his
mind was who the next president was
going to be that was going to give him a
bad time so I said get me get me up
there was and I was really distressed
and as soon as I walked in to the
station I was handed five hundred
dollars in a tape recorder and all the
wire copy that they could pull and they
stuffed by pockets with it and and and
about five hundred bucks and I went
running out into the street and it
weren't my instructions were get to
Dallas any way you can and now there's a
problem too because New York City at the
time was not exactly in panic but there
was a lot of tension and there was a lot
of concern because we didn't know what
was going to follow there was a lot of
concern about whether we're going to be
struck by the Soviet Union was this a
precursor to some attack on our country
that killed the president and then
attack us people wanted to get home they
flooded into the streets they were
grabbing anything they could cabs and
pouring out of the garages and and
Manhattan was in an early form of
gridlock it was practice treats and my
job was to get across the bridge and get
to the airport but we had to stop and go
and stop and go and we tried to get
through the side streets of Manhattan
and everything was jammed we finally
made it across the bridge and the cab
driver because I again here's the case
where I kept throwing dollar bills and
$50 bills to whatever I had in my pocket
at him and he loved it because we kept
going and he said you want to get to
where we going Idlewild right I don't
know why later named Kennedy
Airport and it was quite a distance away
in those days I mean now you can get
there in minutes but in any event where
where the the challenge was to get to
the airport and find an airplane going
to Dallas and he said I'll get you there
and he took the side streets and I think
we cut across you know 15 lawns that day
we were going through through hanging
laundry I think we must have we must
have killed at least two or three dogs
and maybe a cat getting there but I
can't say keep going we were going
through the side streets parallel to the
Van Wyck Expressway and we were plugging
along as he keep going keep going
and finally we went around the the
traffic and we got back on the highway
we got to the airport and I said take me
to Delta Airlines I took a shot any
airline I want and find out what's going
on out here and I went running in and
and I told the cab driver you stay right
here I don't want to lose you and I gave
him another $20 that he stayed and I
went running in and I'm screaming at the
desk clerk what are you going to Texas
are you going to Dallas and he said
nobody's going anywhere the airport's
closed all the airport's of the country
are closing now what but he says that's
a plane that American Airlines is
organizing it's a special flight I think
the Secret Service has has organized and
you better get over to American great so
he a cabdriver took me to America and I
had him stay went in and I verified this
that there was a plane being prepared it
was a plane that was supposed to go to
California I believe but was canceled by
the Secret Service and the FBI they just
told the passengers you're not going
anywhere
this plane is commandeered virtually and
any reporter that could get there and
the Secret Service agents from New York
and an FBI and any reporter that could
get there viata Press Pass could get on
and so I'm gonna end it here I'll get
you down to Dallas and then I'll pick it
up after that because we got okay okay
so I let me just finish it up this is
the tag the last thing I saw before we
took off at my and now I felt better
about everything at least I was on the
airplane I didn't feel very good about
the story but a last thing I saw was the
public relations director of American
Airlines at the time running up the
steps before they pulled the steps away
and we took off with
with about five bottles of booze in his
hands and and and some sandwiches and
that's what we had on the way down so
okay where they were trying to take care
of us anyway so we took off at Dallas
and that's where my coverage started all
right so you're flying to Dallas Sid
where were you and what were some of the
problems that you've had here well I was
on press bus number one with among
others Bob Donovan then of Los Angeles
Times and Bob Pierpoint of CBS News I
had been in Fort Worth the night before
with the President and mrs. Kennedy I
should point out that this is one this
was her first trip political trip out
since almost since the election she had
had a tragedy that summer they lost
Patrick Bouvier a little child about two
or three days old
this was the first time she really was
exposed to this political atmosphere
which she didn't enjoy particularly and
I think we all noticed and I think Bob
Clark mentioned this to me some time ago
that it was the first time we ever saw
Kennedy show affection to mrs. Kennedy
in public he was really in a bashful
person from all you've heard about him
and he took her by the hand and took her
over to the crowd at the fence in Fort
Worth so that she could meet some of the
well-wishers that morning and we never
saw her happier than she was that
morning leaving Fort Worth in that I
call it a raspberry two-piece suit I
wrote an article for American heritage
and the editors changed that the pink I
don't think mrs. Kennedy would have
called it think in any case we took off
for Dallas I was on press bus number one
going into town the crowds were very
warm enthusiastic there were some signs
that were negative but not very many not
what we expected because there had been
some problems in Dallas with Adlai
Stevenson before that where he was
heckled and hit in the head with a
placard but we saw none of that in
Dallas and we drove downtown around
Dealey Plaza and that's where we heard
the shots
there were three distinct shots I didn't
think the first one was a shot but Bob
Pierpoint said without any doubt those
were gunshots and then we noticed up
ahead that the presidential limousine
had disappeared from the motorcade it
just had taken off
and we did see people running we saw
people parents shielding their children
on this grassy knoll and we asked the
bus driver to catch the limousine and
there's no way that city bus was gonna
catch the presidential limousine it had
taken off at 70 miles an hour so we went
to the Trade Mart where the president
was supposed to speak and they were I
think a couple of thousand people in
there
we ran through the hall like of a herd
of elements looking for the pressroom I
called my office and said that the shots
had been fired in the motorcade we don't
know what happened to the president my
bureau chief Jim Snyder said it looks
like the president's in a place called
Parkland Hospital yet over there so I
filed a piece on what I'd seen up to
that point and then I ran outside with
my Olivetti typewriter and I was waving
it in the air and they black gentlemen
in a Cadillac white Cadillac saw me
stopped the car rolled the window down
said are you reporter and I said yes he
said I'll get you to Parkland Hospital
and we took off like a rocket and went
to Parkland and I filed some stories
from there we heard the president was
still alive but very gravely wounded I
saw a group of reporters down a hallway
and there were two Catholic priests one
of his name was father Oskar Huber 67
years old as I recall and I heard him
say over the crowd of reporters he's
dead all right I've given him the last
rites that these two priests had gone
through the hospital I talked to several
groups of reporters because they'd
already been downstairs in the lower
level when I saw them and then I went to
the phone and I I told Washington not to
put this on the air I said the priest
says he's dead and I don't think you
ought to put it on the air I've not
confirmed it and we're waiting for a
briefing and it was agreed that we would
not go on the air with that said we
didn't put that on the air when I when
the announcement was finally made in the
little nurses training room it was made
by Malcolm Kilduff associate press
secretary the president Pierre Salinger
was on his way to Asia with a group of
government officials Kilduff was in
tears
he could barely speak the words he told
me later just about a year ago that he
opened his mouth and nothing came out he
had been downstairs with the Kennedys
with mrs. Kennedy and the staff and he
was the one that had to go to President
Johnson and tell him he had to talk to
the press and make the announcement and
this is Kilduff story he went to Lyndon
Johnson and looked at him and he said
mr. president
and he said Johnson was startled because
he was the first person ever to call
Johnson mr. president and I have to tell
the press that the President Kennedy is
dead and Johnson said wait a few minutes
until I leave we don't know whether this
is an international conspiracy or not
so Kilduff waited a few minutes then
went upstairs the press room and in
tears he said John F Kennedy died at
1:00 p.m. today Central Standard Time in
Dallas he died of a gunshot wound to the
brain and bedlam broke out in that press
room I ran for a phone everybody ran for
the phones and while I was filing a
White House Transportation office
official Jiggs father it wouldn't father
grabbed me by the shoulder while I was
on the air live and said come with me we
need a pool immediately and I said I was
the pool last night in Fort Worth it's
not my turn I'm filing I've got to do
this story he said no you must come with
me
so he took he dragged me from the phone
and we picked up Chuck Roberts of
Newsweek Merriman Smith of the United
Press International the the Dean of the
White House Correspondents he was a
great reporter truly they put us an
unmarked police car and they didn't tell
us where we were going and we raced to
Love Field which is the airport where we
came in
we're Air Force One was waiting Johnson
was already there we which we didn't
know on the way to the airport we heard
on the police radio that they suspect
had been apprehended in the theater I
asked the police officer driving the car
if you would phone myopathy get his
office to phone my office to tell him
where I was they didn't know where I
won't disappear to and he said no we're
maintaining radio silence we don't know
whether there are other killers so we
got to the airport just as the casket
was being
put aboard Air Force One and the Johnson
has already aboard the airplane yeah I
can go on and because you were actually
the pool reporter who was inside Air
Force one mr. Johnson took the old men
and we hold that for just a second and
they will come back because I think
that's a very the way I as many of you
in the because I've told the story about
a thousand times now the way I got to
Dallas that day as I was the night
police reporter for the Fort Worth
star-telegram and I was very upset
because I hadn't been assigned to cover
Kennedy when he came to Fort Worth that
night but the next day when he was shot
I was asleep because I didn't get off
till 3 o'clock in the morning and I
normally slept well past noon and my
brother who was in high school came in
and woke me up and said you better get
to work the president's been shot now it
was just it's completely discombobulated
to find out this news to make a long
story short and by the time I got to the
city room they had come over the radio
that the president was dead and I was
just trying to help answer the phones a
woman I picked up one phone and she says
there anybody there and give me a ride
to Dallas and I said lady you know this
is not the taxi service and besides the
president's been shot and she said yes I
heard it on the radio I think my son is
the one that they've arrested and it was
Lee Harvey Oswald's mother and so I
wearing my snap brim hat because when we
worked on the police beat in those days
we never told people who we were if they
asked we didn't lie about it but if they
wanted to assume that we were detectives
that's what we let him assume the joke
was that our view of the First Amendment
was that everyone had a right to talk to
the Star Telegram
even when they didn't know they were
talking to the Star Telegram
and that was sort of sort of the rules
of the road so anyway since I had a
little triumph sports car I thought well
I can't take this woman to Dallas in
this open two-seater sports car so I
went to the auto editor and in those
days the local car dealers we give the
auto editor a car and free gas to drive
for a week and then he would write a
little road report about it in the
Sunday paper the reviews were generally
good as you
as you might imagine so i said bill what
kind of car you got and he said a
Cadillac his name was Bill Foster and so
we went on in that Cadillac and bill and
I picked up mrs. Oswald she was standing
out on the order front the curb and
drove her over to over to Dallas so
that's how I got there and I want to
pick up on something that that Sid said
and that also Ike said one of the things
that's kind of forgotten about that day
is yes it was a shock I mean none of us
had ever nothing like this had ever
happened we weren't used to these
violent events and in a good way to kind
of understand how it was we could all
now remember exactly where we were and
what we were doing that day but ask
yourself can you still can you remember
immediately where you were when Ronald
Reagan was shot it's very difficult
because there were so many violent
events that happened between the Kennedy
assassination and that shooting that by
that time sadly we had almost become
used to it but the other thing that I
think in and you all mentioned it that I
think people don't remember is that in
addition to this shock that nothing like
this had ever happened there was fear
almost like there was after 9/11 because
we did not know what was going on this
was the height of the Cold War the
bombers of the Strategic Air Command
were put on the highest alert the
borders of Mexico were closed off
because people thought this might be the
prelude to some sort of a war with the
Soviet Union so in addition to the shock
there was this fever that hung over
everybody we just didn't know and it
would be hours before we we understood
what was happening let me just go right
back to Sid you got on the airplane what
was it like in there as Johnson took the
old the the plane of been sitting on the
ground since we arrived about 10 o'clock
in the morning or nine o'clock in the
morning so there was a hot beautiful
sunny day and it was sweltering on the
airplane the shades have been drawn went
back into the presidential suite into a
conference room it's a gold laminated
tapestry walled room I counted about 27
people in there and I saw Lyndon Johnson
and some many of the Kennedy staff
members and I saw some people I didn't
know they were
since Texas congressman there and
Johnson asked whether the press had
arrived and he was told by kilduff who
had already arrived at the airport that
we were here and we could proceed
Johnson that point asked one of his
aides to see if mrs. Kennedy used the
words see if mrs. Kennedy would like to
stand with us they sent word back to
mrs. Kennedy she was seated with the
casket in the rear of the plane they
removed two to four seats in the back of
Air Force One they get this heavy bronze
casket in there and she said she'd like
to join us but she wants some time to
compose herself and a few minutes later
she entered the room there was silence
for just a moment and then the sobs
broke out among some of the Kennedy
staff people they just couldn't hold it
back Johnson went over took her by both
hands and moved her over to his left
mrs. Johnson was on his right he asked
for a glass of ice water he sipped the
glass of ice water and then he told
judge the judge whose to proceed she'd
been brought from downtown Dallas Judge
Sarah Hughes it had an old friend of
Lyndon John's friend of Johnson's and
appointed by John Kennedy yes to the
federal bench I think on Johnson's
recommendation as part of his patronage
she she administered the oath I remember
I was very concerned about being the
pool reporter on the story of the sighs
I never covered anything like this and
never thought I would and so I was
scared to death that I would get
everything right and so I used my watch
I I clocked the oath at 28 seconds time
was 2:38 p.m. Central Standard Time
Johnson took the oath she said so help
me God at the end of it and he repeated
that and then there was an effort by
some people to come over and shake his
hand and he discouraged any
congratulatory remarks he kissed mrs.
Johnson then he turned in kissed mrs.
Kennedy
I noticed that mrs. Kennedy when she
moved I could see the rest of her
clothing her stockings were streaked
with blood her skirt had streaks of
blood her right hand and wrist had blood
on it and there was
and yield because she had cradled his
head for the president's head in her lap
in in the limousine and Johnson then
with great resolve I thought said let's
get airborne the instructions were to
take the oath in Dallas and the
instructions came from the president's
brother the Attorney General Robert
Kennedy take the oath in Dallas and then
get out of there and that's what they
did and swindled kept a Colonel Jim
swindle was the pilot of Air Force One
started to move down the runway I got
off the airplane I was told that there
were only two seats left on the plane
Merriman Smith the wire service reporter
got one of them and Smith and I would
have to flip a coin with Chuck Roberts
for the second seat and because I was a
broadcaster and I could use the
information and get back on the
telephone and report the story and
Newsweek doesn't go to press with until
Saturday night I told Chuck Roberts of
Newsweek I'll get off and so I got off
the plane I got off with with the judge
Hughes and she was in tears walked down
the stairway and she told me that she
had been appointed by Mike Kennedy as I
was going down the stairs Merriman Smith
yells at me going down the stairs the
oath was given at 2:37 p.m. Central
Standard Time and I nodded my head and I
now I had to get the reports of the
other reporters all right then you did
that let's go back now to Dallas Bob
Clark what happened then you were with
the heat racing on to the hospital not
knowing where we're going but this the
motorcade had taken off as fast as it
could accelerate the hospital was four
miles away there wasn't anybody in our
car who had the faintest idea that the
President had been shot or that anybody
up a head had been wounded there is a
tale of Smitty picking up the telephone
and file the filing what became a solid
very celebrated bulletin I'll leave that
for the Q&A anybody who's interested in
the details of what happened between
Sperry and Jack look Bob talked a little
bit about the relationship in those days
between the report
and the officials like The Secret
Service was it like yes when we get to
the hospital or I have a news page for
that okay well we'll tell it about it
right now
okay when we we did not have any idea
that we were going to the hospital
though we and we the Warren Commission
said we went at speeds up to 80 miles an
hour that's probably a slight
exaggeration that we may have hit 70 as
we careened into the entrance to the
hospital we said my god somebody's been
hurt up there we jumped out you didn't
know at this point that the president it
was the president no idea
jumped out of the car raced up to where
Kennedy was standing now there's my news
page the today the Secret Service would
would keep the White House press back
two blocks if they could get a way with
it in those days there were only four
pool reporters who got onto the hospital
The Secret Service knew all of us
trusted us and incredibly let us run up
and stand right next to the car and
stare down at Kennedy so we did this the
four of us independently there it was a
frozen scene that was the surprise to me
there were Secret Service standing
around and and number of other people
but nobody was saying anything mrs.
Kennedy sat without looking in a state
of deep shock she had the president was
was lying with his head on the side of
his head on the vaccines he was cradling
his head in her arms or he almost had
his head in her lap there were no
stretchers it was a two or three minutes
before the stretchers came out there
from there we were at the emergency
entrance of the hospital and though the
stretchers came out for him Polly was
stretched out here he and his wife and
then on the jump seats in the back he
was stretched out on the floor I have
kicked myself later I did not do a very
good job of absorbing everything I could
see you know but the for reporters none
of them
saw Kennedy wounds at that stage and
that has to be that Jackie was
deliberately shielding yes Bob how did
you get to Forster first report out
because we didn't have cell phones and
have a surprisingly easy Smitty and I
made the decision at about the same time
we I waited till the stretchers arrived
and they were starting to put Kennedy
aboard a stretcher and I thought I
better get inside the hospital where I
thought I could get a telephone or I'll
be cut out and so Smitty and I at the
same time started trotting the ward the
emergency entrance at the hospital
Smitty asked as he went in where there's
a phone and got one there by I asked
where there was another and was sent to
an adjoining room and was on a phone in
30 seconds
so telephones surprisingly were no
problem those days so we had had only
the the one telephone in the car I just
by coincidence spoke with the doctors
that were at the hospital that received
Kennedy and talked to him last night and
they said there was no question that the
president was dead when when he comes
well that's been examined at great
length there were faint signs of one of
the doctors said there was faint signs
but they said oh yes now let me that's
just we all know what happened next in
and we've we've heard the how you talked
about the announcement let's let's fast
forward Ike to Sunday Oswald has been
arrested he's been brought in he is shot
JD Tippit one of the policemen in the
process as they tried to arrest him then
we they finally get him in the in the
theater and they bring him in you were
there when did you get there did you get
there in time to see him you saw him
that I saw him later they right man
along with everybody else but you know
I'll get you down to Dallas in a big
hurry yeah we got on the airplane and we
didn't know it at the time but we flew
first to Washington because they had
other agents that they had to pick up
and that was the fastest turnaround I've
ever had in an airplane and we must've
been on the ground six minutes of bad
up again we're out of there and and now
the next the next problem was to try to
find out what was happening on the
ground we had three hours in the air and
and we didn't know what was happening
you know and so we talked to Pilate and
asked him is there any way we can get
some word from the ground and he said
I'll patch the broadcasts as we pass
over cities we can take the broadcast
that we can pull out of the air and
patch them into the cabin so y'all you
guys will know what's going on so he had
a almost a built-in briefing room as we
passed over one city we found out that
they were chasing someone from the
School Book Depository the next city his
name is Lee Harvey Oswald that we're
writing this down in cave we keep his
vital statistics how old and so forth
what he did and then they captured him
in the Texas theater and all of these
events were a tense firing on the ground
and we had the story when we hit Love
Field at around 8 o'clock that night we
went right over to the police
headquarters and I worked the story
pretty that routinely because there was
things that were breaking all over the
place and I had to file and if you had a
telephone of course there were no cell
phones in those days but if you had a
way to get a telephone you were golden
because you were out with your story you
didn't do anybody any good if you had
all the information in the world no way
to get it out so my challenge was to try
to find a telephone even at that point
and I did I filed a couple of stories so
as long as I was in and I established my
presence in Dallas I was ok but slowly
in the evening the pressure started to
build on police chief Jesse Curry to
bring down Oswald and finally the
reporters that really knew him were
really putting real pressure on him the
local guys and also the national people
are pouring in from all over the country
you have to understand what kind of a
situation that was people from you know
Canada and from Mexico and everybody was
turning up and in Dallas and running
over there and trying to get access to
the story and the police didn't really
know how to handle this I think this was
probably the first time they had had
anything of this magnitude there were no
rules basically anybody who had a press
card could get in
and they didn't try to control that the
media the massive media that was there
and in any event I we had almost total
access to that third floor where they
were questioning Oswald in a couple of
times they brought him out people yelled
at it and you see it in the in the
pictures of but tell us about meeting
that guy you were looking for the phone
that looked like he might be a cop I
think that's a I'm getting all right
I'll get to that I was just about to go
down there by the way okay III but I
thought it would might be interesting to
for you
journalists and so forth and the general
public to know what kind of pressure was
being put on the police chief Jessie
Currie we were some of them reporters
was saying are you beating him up
because he had a mouse over his eye and
that curry said no we're not beating oh
well bring him down and let's see him
and he finally acquiesced he caved and
he said okay we're gonna bring him in at
midnight in the lineup room but no
questions and we said oh of course no
questions my god absolutely no questions
so midnight as well comes in shackled
two to three detectives surrounded by
people and so forth and of course as
soon as he hits the door everybody yells
out of me or even yelling at him in the
hallway you know did you shoot the
president how did you get hurt what are
they doing you why did you shoot the
president he just kind of Daisy honey
they bring him up front and we all
gathered around and we all showered kept
shouting at him and that's when he said
that's what I've been accused of so
somebody L did you shoot the president I
think I yelled at one point we were all
yelling the same thing why did you shoot
the president
and he he said no that's what I've been
accused of that's what I've heard
but I forget the exact quote but he
denied it in effect and and and then
they said okay that's it the rules
broken here the ground rules are broken
list and they started to take it out but
at least we had some sound with him and
he then another reporter as with Anik
turned and he answered him again you
know saying that he wanted to see a
lawyer and anyway the after that event
that everybody's talking you know the
reporters are exchanging notes and What
did he say what did he hear it was a
quotient and Henry weighed that this
attorney of Dallas County is having a
press conference out
side of the room whereas Wald was and
he's talking about the legal
ramifications and what they're going to
do with Oswald and so forth and then III
was going to go over and listen to him
and suddenly this little guy comes
running up to me and he had a gray
pinstripe dark grey pinstripe suit suit
and he had a snap brim Fedora not not
the one like yours of course it was like
it yeah yeah I don't know but anyway he
kept running up to me and I thought I
came running up to me and I thought he
was a vice cop now if he was a vice cop
he would have a telephone he'd have an
office so maybe I didn't promote him
into letting me use his telephone and I
was you know he came up to and he said
you a reporter and I said yes I'm a
reporter he said where you from New York
I said yes I'm from New York then I had
asked somebody you a cop because he
looked like this sort of this guy that
would hang around bars and bust people
that are trying to have fun and anyway
he said no I'm Jack Ruby I run the
Carousel Club down the block and then he
pulls out his card and he says
hey come on down to the club get some of
you guys some of the other reporters
come out down there we got booze we got
women we got music hey you know we'll
get you whatever you want and I am sort
of I'm really taken aback by the stunned
by this because here the Mexican borders
as you mentioned had locked we don't
know if we're going to be attacked by
the Soviet Union the nation is in chaos
and here is this guy pardon the phrase
pimping the press he was he was out
hustling business for his
strip joint he was a he ran the Carousel
Club which was a strip joint and I
should have mentioned that earlier you'd
know what I'm talking back in any event
I said to him and I wanted a human him
no okay here here's I got your card and
I put it in my pocket here I said keep
it right there I'll get the guys will
all come over to spend a lot of money
there and and and then I said now can
you get me it because he appeared to be
news way around this this police station
and I thought he was above a police buff
so he must know people here and I said
can you get me a telephone he's sorry
you want a phone just a minute
so he goes over to Henry Wade
and he's listening for a while but then
he gets his attention he whispers
something to him he comes running back
to me says come on so he takes me into
Henry Wade's office this is jack ruby
monument who is later to be prosecuted
by Henry Wade for shooting Lee Harvey
Oswald now I have this guy taking me
into his office and I said okay and I
called New York and I fed my piece and
Henry Wade was still talking and I did a
couple of you know unseen things ad lib
things and and and in comes Henry Wade
and I did a telephone interview with him
you know you ask question and a new hand
him the telephone he answers it and
they're recording this in New York and
finally I had everything that I needed
in New York so that they could chop that
stuff up and use it for you know three
or four hours anyway so the phone was
hung up and and I disappeared then I
didn't know where Ruby went until about
two o'clock in the morning I had wrapped
up my coverage at the police station
Oswald was tucked away in his cell the
reporters were filing and so I went over
to the local station and I talked to the
news director there the small radio
station and I said look I need to file
like I need a place to work that's all I
need a telephone so he said oh you just
stay here all night no problem so I was
there with the engineer in the end and
the station was playing dirge music
funeral music there was nope no
commercials it wasn't just a terrible
evening and I started to work on my
little typewriter and there's a ring at
the door I didn't answer it the engineer
came down and he opens the door and in
comes Jack Ruby with two bags of
groceries and I look up and I said he
says that weird guy again there's that
strange guy what's he doing here and he
said hi fellas I saw the lights out I
thought you might need something to eat
you know you guys working hard he said
here's take some sandwiches and some
cokes and I did not eat those sandwiches
I want you to know I think I didn't
trust this guy at all I did have a coke
because it was sealed
but but no kidding I mean somebody walks
in and says here eat one of my
sandwiches you know who knows what's in
it but anyway III then dismissed him as
a as a buff as a guy who likes to hang
around the excitement now he had the
world pressed to plate to play to to
cater to not only the police but the
fire people and he left and I finished
my work and I filed morning new stuff
and I was by that time it was sunrise so
I had to go back to coverage I didn't
sleep for two days there till I finally
finally got some and anyway Saturday
I'll get you into Monday Sunday Saturday
was a more or less a routine day of
piling stories
nothing eventful happened to me but I'm
sure happened to the yes your experience
with Oswald by the now I was sent in the
next morning to cover Oswald at the
police headquarters there were already
stories in the morning papers about how
rowdy the press had been the night
before so when I went in I thought I
will try to talk to the chief of police
Jesse curry I went by his office he's
sitting alone in his office I went in
and told him I was there for ABC and I
know you've had trouble with the press
what will the rules be today he told me
the same thing you'd been told the night
before you may see Oswald he may stop
and say something to you but there are
no questions that'll be the rule today
no questions well forty five minutes
later by great coincidence I was
standing in a hallway and I just picked
out no reason to suspect Oswald would be
around with a dead microphone I was
hooked up to a camera cool about thirty
feet away
suddenly the door oppositely pops open
and here comes Oswald flanked by Secret
Service and FBI walked directly over to
my microphone said into my dead
microphone I want to contact mr. apt of
New York City to serve as my attorney
now there's a Q&A here how many of you
know today who John apt was how many do
I see anybody and nobody well that
doesn't surprise me but it
me because Jon Apps identity the reason
you don't know who John apt is is
because the FBI the the Justice
Department the Johnson administration
didn't want you at that time to know who
John apt was and there
I'm not going to spread any suspicions
about Soviet involvement I'm telling
this story just to show how much the FBI
and Justice Department controlled the
information at that point John apt was
the chief counsel of the American
Communist Party he was the pave we now
know he was a paid chief counsel paid by
the Soviet Union if I was well had
gotten the attorney he wanted apt
happened to be out of town in New York
if he'd gotten the attorney he wanted
his attorney would have been on the
payroll of the Soviet Union but the
administration was so concerned
understandably they they thought we
could be talking about World War three
is it's we were up to now
World War three if the Soviets were
involved so they said not to this day
they have not released information on
John after I developed sort of an
obsession about him but that John apt
took the Fifth Amendment before the
house on American Activities Committee
during the Alger Hiss case from that
time you better believe the FBI started
compiling a thick file on him but up
until the day they have never put out
their file on that John apt and I tried
to the lag when I worked for ABC in my
closing years a few years ago and
covered the assassination records Review
Board
I tried to get any FBI records on John
apt there were just a couple of
meaningless releases and
but to this day you would have trouble
finding out any more about we're gonna
go to Q&A here and just let's bring sit
in for one final I guess we haven't got
Oswald shot yeah yeah but but I did hit
that long airplane ride down but I would
like to because there are a lot of
budding journalists in the room I'm told
yes um I took this out of a book that's
written by Darwin Payne is that was a
dallas news reporter detective from
dallas testifying before the Warren
Commission regarding media at the Dallas
police station when Oswald was shot this
is what the detective said he said he
was disgusted with them the media if you
ever slopped hogs and thrown down a pair
of slop and saw them Rush after it you
would understand what it was like up
there about the same situation and then
another comment was as police chief
curry was explaining Oswald's transfer
one reporter brazenly scribbled notes on
the pan he'd prompt on the Chiefs back
let's uh let's do go quickly to I can
and give us a little capsule he was
standing there I had been sent over to
the courthouse they were going to Brandt
transfer Oswald from the city jail to
the county jail I was at the courthouse
waiting for him to get there Ike was
there where they brought him out of the
city jail what happened at CBS they used
to call it take 15 seconds out yeah
which is what I had had to have done to
my pieces all the time thank you for
reminding me to be succeed here we go
that morning I got up early of course
and went over to the jail to watch
Oswald
being transferred we were told by chief
curry that if you get here by 10:30 you
won't miss anything now I was very
cynically of suspicious of that too
because being a New York reporter I mean
police would never do that in New York
they'd never tell you when they were
moving him so anyway I trusted him and I
got there 10:30 and he was still there
and I I decided that I was going to try
to one-up everybody else and I wanted to
get a scoop and I went over to I went up
to the third floor where they were
interrogating Oswald and and everybody
else was down in the basement they were
getting set for that exit shot and you
know
with the cops and that famous scene that
we all know however I thought that if I
could get an interview with Oswald as he
came out I'd just have him say anything
I would have a big big score and then I
would get down to the basement somehow
well how how would you get down Pappas I
as myself well let's see there's a
stairwell there it goes right to the
basement what I did was I practice
running down the stairwell twice to see
whether I would be stopped by a cop or
something
to see whether I had an exit because I
always if I was going to take a chance
like that if I were to take a chance
like that I would I would want to back
up escape route or a backup plan so I I
practice said this is an example of how
loose the security was at the building
that day out and I everything was fine
outcomes Oswald and I went forward with
my microphone and I asked him do you
have anything to say in your I wanted to
say defense but a policeman a detective
threw me up against the wall and they
hustled him to the end of the of the
corridor to where the elevators are and
they put him they shoved him in the
elevator and and down he goes now my
heart is leaping out of my chest because
I said to myself you will never work in
this business again how could you take
such a chance there goes the best story
you'll ever cover in your life and
you're not there to report it and you
know you'll never be should be fired
yeah I should be fired but I got to get
down there so I flew down the steps it
on the way down it occurred to me what
if the doors locked now I really did and
I reached for the door and it opened
what relief I went in and now we're to
report this story everybody was already
jammed in and and now where's Oswald I
said is he gone no I saw him in the in
the office of the of the security people
they were signing him out they were
giving him back his shoelaces and his
wallet and whatever they take from you
when you're arrested because he was
going to go to another jail and anyway I
had caught up to the story and I was
pretty happy about that but where do you
where do you report this so I saw a
little opening in the chase car you know
behind the the wagon that they were
going to take outs world away and and
ice waste in and I move
and I moved in with my big New York
elbows and I know I had a look at the
door to the to the car and I could
report that Oswald starts coming down
and I didn't know it at the time but as
I was pushing right in right in front of
Lee heart of Jack Ruby rather who was
waiting to shoot Lee Harvey Oswald and I
blocked his view I'm sure for a while
now down T these are all split seconds
these things are happening in
nanoseconds I was coming toward me and I
start to talk him up to my position
saying that he was led by captain
Wilfred suit interrogating changed into
a black sweater and just when he gets
over to where babysitter's just a few
inches away I went forward again and I
said do you have anything to say in your
defense and just as I was saying defense
I heard footsteps I saw a black
streaking from me and then I said
defense and I felt I felt the impact of
the weapon on my body and I saw the
flash on his black sweater of Oswald's
black sweater and I was well moaned and
he went down now there's a pause in my
report because my brain my computer in
my head is trying to catch up with
what's happened here what have I just
seen have I seen the assassin of the
President of the United States himself
assassinated my god he's been shot of
course he's been shot so the other
thought that what threw me and it was
just an impulse wasn't a thought it was
just an urge I said if you never say
anything ever again into a microphone
you must say it now this is history
don't freeze that was my main my main
concern don't get so panicked that you
can't report this story but how do you
put what I just saw into words what I
said was what I saw in front of me which
is what a reporter was supposed to do
tell just tell me what's happening and I
said there's a shot a shot rang out now
there's a fight they're fighting for a
gun and I saw a gun being struggled with
the people caved in on Ruby they dragged
Oswald back through the double doors and
I kind of had a chance to look at that
and and I saw Oswald's body and his that
the two detectives that fell in sort of
wood leaning over him they stayed we
covered and
the two the two detectives then dragged
him back they didn't even take his
handcuffs off as far as I know they were
pulling him back by his hands through
the double doors and then I really
disappeared but we didn't even know it
was Ruby then I did not see his face all
I saw was a black flash in front of me
and out comes a detective after maybe
ten minutes of a lot of hubbub and about
a lot of notes and people in put them
what did you see blah blah and out comes
a detective and he and we said who was
it who shot him and he said well Jack
Ruby shot that old boy and I said wait a
minute Jack Ruby
I got Jack Ruby's car nobody knows about
that boom so I was just I was staggered
by that I was stunned by that but but
but I felt I mean I was saddened by the
entire event but but but I felt that for
professionally I felt very fortunate
professionally I felt very fortunate
that I was that close to everything of
that and that I I have actually met this
person before and I've never covered
anything like it since nor I think of
any of us over there okay we got time
for a couple of questions Helen why did
he do
why did Ruby shoot us well okay my
theory is and it's only a theory but
it's you know the years of speculation
and reading and so forth
Jack Ruby was a miniscule character in a
mighty oligarchy and oil oligarchy oil
Kingdom like Dallas he was nothing it
was a guy who ran a strip club he felt
he had his power and and and famed
through his place he knew the cops that
way he would get the cops traits they
would come in and whatever else he knew
the politicians cuz they came in he may
have known some of the football he was
Jack Ruby you know he want to go
somewhere he go to Jack's place I
thought afterwards just looking and
examining what what his what he said he
did it for he wanted to avenge Jackie
now
if he felt so terribly about Jackie why
would he have come up to me trying to
hustle business that night he would have
been so so upset and it's so fixed on
Jackie and everything else and I don't I
never believed that because I had an
angle on his that nobody else did and
that is a personal encounter with Jack
Ruby on the Friday before he shot Oswald
and and I said to myself this guy is
it's not an upset person he is he's he's
you know he's quite sane and now I think
that he could have because in those days
if you examine the temperament of Texas
in that time carrying guns openly was
was quite allowed and there was also
something called the crime of passion
law and my theory is that Jack Ruby felt
that he could shoot Lee Harvey Oswald
maybe due to years of time or so three
years and come out a big hero and be
something in his that's what I think I
think he thought he was going to be
somebody and I think he thought he would
wind up as a national hero question if
you have the opportunity to have any
dealings or exchanges with Edward Edward
Clark you know who I'm talking about
he's prominently named in this new book
blood money and power
how LBJ killed JFK what that book is no
I think really please this is the father
of our current well I don't care George
Washington the book is is totally
discredited there's nothing in that book
that's true any other question yes
a disappearance Piron see that time was
USA more with Kennedy was president with
Cuba I think that's one of them other
conspiracy theory prison by suppressing
Johnson was interested to become
president do you believe there was any
there was a conspiracy or not III
eveness I have seen no evidence that
he's convinced me that there was I'm
keeping an open mind about it among
other things people aides to Lyndon
Johnson say that Lyndon Johnson always
wondered if there was some connection
with Castro but he had no evidence of
that it was one of the things that
people wondered about but I do not
believe that there were seen no evidence
to that effect that convinces me yeah
that's what the Warren Commission said
the Warren Commission did not say there
was no conspiracy the Warren Commission
said there was no evidence of a
conspiracy and nothing solid has come
out in the 40 years since 73 House
Select Committee on assassinations
taking the Kennedy assassination is a
first project concluded among other
things that there were because of sound
tests that they had two shooters not one
secondly that it was the result probably
of a conspiracy but they did not say
what the conspiracy was who was it who
were the conspirators and what they
offered no details so that's the closest
that we've come to any suggestion at all
that this was a conspiracy and they did
mention if I have of just a few more
seconds they did eliminate the Soviet
Union as a conspirators conspirator and
I believe the Cuban government now the
Soviet government Cuban government but
they also said that anti-castro Cubans
may have been involved on an individual
basis with not as a group so that's
that's as close as they come to that Bob
I followed the story for 40 years I read
a lot of books
with more or less an open mind but I
have felt from the beginning that Oswald
acted alone I would mention people can't
understand what Oswald's Motors or if
you really want to get in side Oswald's
mind read there Priscilla Johnson
McMillan's book Marita and Lee she is a
fascinating figure who was the only
person who knew both Kennedy and Oswald
had worked for Kennedy and interviewed
Oswald in Russia after his defection she
did an excellent book she has a truer
understanding of Oswald the embittered
hater who was hated everybody and
thought the government was out to get
him and I think you'll get the sense of
Oswald's motive if you read that book I
think the best argument that there was
not a conspiracy is that if there were I
think somebody by now would have told it
that would be the thing I overhear
that's the case when we know who deep
throat is but moving right along I think
it's great that you did this book
there's only three people know who deep
throat is well why hasn't he come
forward the third what would you talk a
little bit about the role of television
at this time I mean it was really
central in terms of a real turning point
we really all watched television in a
way we never had before and also I
wonder if you talked about how well you
thought the press covered the event well
I think it was a defining moment for
television it really brought television
news into its adulthood for for four
days the television networks did nothing
but cover this set the assassination and
the aftermath and the funeral 175
million Americans tuned in over that
four-day period the network cameramen
were told not to take any close-ups of
the Kennedy family and st. Matthew's
Cathedral there was a great deal of
reverence in the way the story was
covered
I think that the fact that I was not the
only person who heard father Oscar
Huber's say Kennedy was dead who didn't
use it on the air until we could get an
official confirmation I don't think that
would happen today but don't you think
said that this was the turning point in
the sense up until that point what
validated events was seeing it written
down in black and white from that
weekend forward survey after survey has
shown that from then on it was
television that validated events it was
television that most people turned to to
get their news and I think that brace
the difference yes I I think what
television brought to the nation at that
point one of the reasons why it was a
defining moment was that this was the
first event that we as a nation ever
watched on television as a whole there
are other events that we could point to
one the Queen Elizabeth the carnation
for one a lot of people it was just a
day or so but but this was the first
time we've had a national crisis that
was told to us by television and I think
that the presence of the anchor people
the fact that we were breathing some
assurance into the public through the
through facial contact eye contact with
the people who are telling us the news I
don't think the newspapers could deliver
that you couldn't you couldn't talk to
the editorial board if you were worried
about the survival of the country you
had to listen to the soothing words
sometimes of Cronkite let's go back here
yes ma'am
are you really Jenna know wondering
perspective of history it's the same
stigma still associated
with Dallas when people think of of that
place and the faculty well I don't think
so but someone else with more than half
the countries who was wasn't born when
Kennedy was assassinated so that's the
big factor in this thing I don't I don't
think Dallas still has the same stigma
as it did a few years after the
assassination you know let me just add
one thing for example the sixth floor
museum after this happened the Texas
schoolbook depository of where Oswald
was there were people in Dallas who
wanted to bulldoze that building they
wanted to erase it from history they
didn't want to think about it and wiser
heads prevail the county finally bought
the building they now have county
offices in that building and up on the
upper floors is this what they call the
sixth floor museum this could have been
something like a bizarre Ripley's
Believe It or Not kind of place it is
not it is a repository for information
it's become a place where scholars can
go and I think it has something to do
with with the changes that did come
about in Dallas democracies need an
accurate history and the people there I
think have done a wonderful job in that
Museum I think is one example of it yes
moment for a moment on the job that I
think the press in the way and
broadcasting have done over the years in
covering the assassination the instant
job of covering this horrible tragedy
and what it meant to the country and and
tracing through the history of the
Kennedy administration a good job I'd
give them fairly high points on that but
the conspiracy theory covers over the 40
years the media generally the Washington
Post is done a number of stories
building up seizing on conspiracy
theories and and playing off to my my
own parent
ABC was criticized by Jerry Ford several
years ago Ford by is the only surviving
member there were Warren Commission it
was criticized by Ford for its role in
some
television programming that buildup
conspiracy theories so I would put a
fair share of the blame there have been
a lot of mysterious elements in the
assassination and it's been illogical
for the American public
to be suspicious but the press generally
has disappointed me by too often
choosing the best story as it approached
the assassination and the best story has
always been some probably cockeyed
conspiracy theory
alright well folks I'm very sorry the
the powers at me or signaled me that it
is time to bring this two to a
conclusion I think the one thing we can
all agree upon is this was a day that
changed America it was a turning point
in our history thank you very much